hello my name is Luis Gomez and I'm a
postdoctoral associate at the Medical
School and so first of all I would like
to thank you for your interest in this
talk and today I'm going to talk about
computational techniques that I'm
developing to improve the targeting and
precision of transcranial magnetic
stimulation or TMS a non-invasive brain
simulation technique specifically I hope
that you can learn about PMS and get an
illustration of how computational
techniques enable the development and
optimal deployment of medical
technologies and so first of all what is
TMS TMS is a non-invasive technique
where one or more coils driven by low
frequency current pulses placed on the
scalp is used to generate magnetic
fields which in turn induce electric
field in the conductive brain matter
these electric fields then in turn
modulate brain activity specifically
brain regions with large electric fields
are typically stimulated by TMS TMS is
used in cognitive neuroscience to study
brain function so for example a
neuroscientist might use the coil to
stimulate a cortical region that is
thought to be responsible for finger
movement and then the watch for a model
of motor response it is also used as an
fda-approved treatment of depression and
for pre-surgical mapping so there are
many other TMS based therapies being
researched and so one limitation of
transcranial magnetic stimulation is
that PMS coils
fused in shallow regions of them and
this limits the resolution of functional
brain regions that can be resolved by
neuroscience experiments and surgical
brain mapping furthermore getting better
control of PMS fields could result in
more effective TMS therapies so here I
show an illustration of the stimulative
region during TMS on the left side and
so we can see that the stimulated region
is very wide or has a large spread and
it's very shallow or has a very small
penetration depth and so what we would
actually like to see during PMS it's one
in electromagnetics we call it pencil
pattern of stimulation where you have a
very small spread and a large
penetration depth and so that stimulated
region looks like a pencil beam and so
more precisely what we want to do is to
increase the precision of targeting of
PMS and this of course to enable the
development of better PMS therapies and
increase the resolution of neuroscience
experiments that use TMS so another
limitation of transcranial magnetic
stimulation is that there's a lot of
variability in between TMS sessions and
this results in variability in the pms
outcomes and so the variability in the
pms outcomes could be caused by coil
placement there and suboptimal placement
of the coil on the stop so currently in
a clinical setting a cap is placed on
the head and the cap has markers where
the coils should reside these markings
might not be directly under targeted
neural sites or there can be operator
error which causes variation in the pms
induced electric fields there are more
advanced neural navigated TMS systems
that use MRIs along with cameras and
robotic arms to virtually remove the
error in coil placement however these
are expensive and more importantly we do
not know to what extent coil placement
uncertainty results in variability in
the electric field induced on target
targeted cortical sites and so if it
turns out that the coil movement smoking
movements do not result in a large
variation in the electric field induced
in the targeted cortical regions then it
might not be so important to control for
this coil movement and these neuro
navigated systems might not be necessary
if it is the case that the fields are
very sensitive to coil positioning then
neuro navigated procedures would be
absolutely essential and so now that you
know what TMS is all about I'm gonna
tell you about my contributions and
specifically how my work feels to
address these limitations and so in a
nutshell I did
the procedure for synthesizing new TMS
coils that permit the generation of
electric fields that achieve fundamental
trails between vocality depth and energy
and then I use this to design coils
which are twice more focal than existing
ones this is the first improvement and
vocality of PMS coils in decades in
addition I developed an uncertainty
quantification method designed
specifically for TMS that affords about
the sensitivity of PMS procedures to
various parameters such as coil position
and patient to patient variability and
then I use this a framework to assess
the need for these new MRI neuro
navigated PMS systems finally we are
developing computational tools to
determine optimal coil
placements for targeting fields in the
brain I'm gonna briefly talk about all
these starting with the coil designs and
so here I show a picture of a sixteen
coils and these clothes have been ranked
in terms of their spread and depth of
stimulation smaller spread means more
focal coils and we would like to have
small spread so we want to be as close
as possible to the horizontal axis on
this graph and as we move in the
horizontal axis we are increasing the
depth of stimulation and what we can see
here is that there are a number of coils
that sit on a curve that sits closest to
the horizontal axis and they are
currently what's considered the state of
the art and they mostly consist of
what's commercially available or figure
eight oils and so to improve on these
figure eight coils what we do is we use
closed-loop optimizers to determine the
optimal winding pattern then we 3d print
a 3d printer formance with groups where
the coil will windings will recite we
wind our coil and as it turns out a
typical result is that our oils are more
focal and standard figure eight oils and
so the way our optimization works is
that we choose a coil support so this
can be any shape so the quote the coil
windings can sit on a flat spiracle
hemispherical or any kind of
that you can define as a triangle mesh
and a headlock and then we specify a
head model this could be MRI derived or
a generic spherical pet model then we
choose a targeted location that the coil
must stimulate a stimulation threshold
or the total electric field that's
necessary for a region to be labeled as
stimulated we specify a maximum electric
field that the coil can generate in the
brain and maximum energy that the coil
can use then our algorithm finds a coil
which minimizes the stimulated volume
while achieving those objectives and so
here I'm on the I show a graph a drawing
of a coil that's representative of a
typical design coming out of our
algorithm and more importantly when we
decide our coils design by our algorithm
roughly half the spread for any
penetration depth and again I repeat
this is the first significant
improvement in vocality seen in decades
these results here were attained
assuming that we can use arbitrarily
high energy however practical designers
have an energy budget because of the
amount of energy delivered to the brain
is more relative to the current flowing
in the windings so we have we are
limited by the amount of current that
can physically flow through the wire and
as it turns out as the energy is
decreased we lose some performance
relative to our best designs and this
this red card that I show here starts to
approach that of the figure eight oil
and so here for a fixed depth I look at
how the spread varies with the amount of
energy that these oils can use each for
each curve corresponds to a different
oil support type so the black would
represent a coil
who's winding stood on a flat or a
square out of support the green or a
half sphere support and the blue for a
spherical support and we can see for all
of these curves as the energy increases
the spread approaches the value of
the energy on constrain results
furthermore there's higher vocality for
the same energy and depth of a figuring
oil for any of these designs and to
achieve the same vocality as a figure
eight oil we require less energy in fact
there's a reduction of 10 times in
energy and so what we see here is that
the spherical or more conformal coils
are more energy efficient or have better
trade-offs with spread and energy than
the flat ones however when it comes to
aspera mental setting placing a
spherical coil on the head and placing
it on different targets it's quite
difficult and so this is not really a
feasible solution and so to deal with
this we came up with a hat like shape
this shape was derived by using a number
of subject MRIs in finding the maximal
conformal shape that enabled placement
anywhere along the motor strip and here
it's spread and n versus energy is
better than that of the flat foils isn't
slightly worse than that of the
spherical coil and so this this this hat
foil shape enables us to maintain good
energy trade-offs while achieving
improved locality so once we had our
design we field want to match the depth
of a standard figure 8 coil commercial
figure in coil and the way we build it
is with 3d printed reformer with groups
where the windings reside and then we
want two layers of litz wire and measure
the electric fields using an electric
field probe electric field program we
developed in-house and the measured
results matched what we expected from
our predictions more importantly the
electric fields are more vocal than
those of figuring coils these coils are
absolutely 30% more vocal and so we can
see here that the electric fields
measured and predicted are along the
vertical axis and the Hat coil versus
the figure 8 coil are along the
horizontal axis and we can see that B of
the Hat coils generate much more focal
field than the maximum closed and that's
seen by the smaller spot size in the
electric field Maps
and so what distinguished star approach
from previous approaches is that it is
nearly fully computational the design
was done by an optimization algorithm
the manufacturing was mostly done by a
3d printer by using computational
approaches we came up with winding
patterns that were optimal but not
necessarily intuitive and then dirty
printing technologies enabled the
manufacture of more complicated shapes
this in the end resulting oils that
stimulate two times less volume than
conventional foils while matching the
same target at that so these
computational approaches for design
enabled the optimal deployment of PMS
eventually this technique could be
applied to develop personal x-files that
exploit the local gyro and Sokol
geometry of the cortex to deliver more
focal and more targeted stimulation so
this concludes the design part of our
talk now I'm going to talk a little bit
about the uncertainty quantification and
so what we wanted to do here is given a
probabilistic description of the TMS
setup in uncertainty in the coil
placement
uncertainty in the tissue conductivities
uncertainty in the size of the
individual tissues and others and given
all of this we would like to generate
probabilistic predictions for the
electric field specifically we want to
determine the mean standard deviation
and other statistical parameters of the
electric field then we would like to use
this framework determine parameters that
the result is the most variability in
the electric field and so in principle
doing this vuq is quite straightforward
using what's called a Monte Carlo method
and so for example let's assume that we
have two uncertain various parameters
the coil position along the x and y
direction and so the coil can be played
the coil can be centered about any point
on this brain square that I show here so
the way that we could print a
quantification is that dus okay so we
would shoot we would Center the coil up
on
of different positions and then for each
of these positions we can run a
simulation to come up with the electric
field that's generated at a targeted
cortical site then once we have this
ensemble of electric field simulation
results we can just compute statistics
on them to derive the probability
density functions cumulative probability
density functions and then we can
extract me and standard deviations and
other statistical parameters now a
problem with this approach is that it
requires many simulation and as it turns
out to compute it to go from coil
position to electric field it takes
roughly five minutes for a single
simulation so a quick aside I've made
this repository and here's the website
and it has all the methods currently
used and some new ones for another I
seen fields generate during TMX feel
free to download and so again so running
this Monte Carlo requires many
simulations and because of this this
becomes computationally intractable
because we cannot run a high number of
simulations and so to avoid the high
cost of Monte Carlo methods what we do
is we instead of using our
electromagnetic solver we construct a
polynomial surrogate that we can
evaluate rapidly so we first choose a
few points on the random domain and for
these points we run a simulation so
these are very few points so we can run
a simulation for each of these and then
we construct a polynomial fit around
these points and then once we have this
polynomial fit we run the Montecarlo on
the surrogate or the polynomial fit and
this enables us to get the statistics
quite rapidly and so whenever there's a
rapidly very function what we use is
what's called a multi element multi
element probabilistic approach which
adaptively subdivides the random domain
and introduces local polynomials in
order to be able to capture these rapid
variations walk madame ice minimizing
the number of simulator
evaluations that are required
furthermore for increasing for
increasing number of random variables we
use what's called a high dimensional
model representation techniques which
introduces decoupling between variables
iterative Li thereby minimizing the
total number of simulations required to
achieve our accurate polynomial for high
dimensional problems okay so now that
you know all about my method I'm gonna
talk about I'm gonna show you some
experimental results and so that's the
first study we consider coil placement
uncertainty and so the center of the
coil for different realizations can sit
anywhere on this green circular patch
and the radius of this green patch
depends on the type of procedure that is
being used so for clinical procedure
using this cap in place method the
uncertainty the radius of this would be
between 10 to 15 millimeters and for
neuro navigated ones it would be between
2 to 5 millimeters and so here we
consider a the average electric field on
an ROI as our observable and what we
observed and here I show the average
electric fields for different levels of
uncertainty in the coil position and the
90 percent confidence interval what we
observed is that the clinical procedures
have a variation of about 30 volts per
meter whereas the nura navigated ones
have a variation of about 10 watts per
meter or
they reduce the uncertainty by a factor
of 3 and so it's 30 volts per meter
meter really that significant to answer
that here I show a TMS input output
curve the way this curve is generated is
that the coil is placed on the subjects
top directly above the motor cortex and
used to me generate a finger movement a
pulse is delivered each time increasing
the intensity and so starting from a
very low intensity I would generate a
pulse
and then I would figure out what the MEP
or how much finger Ruth and I would plot
that into this graph and then I would
move along the x-axis by increasing the
intensity and I would start to get these
little dots that are depicted here and
then what you see is that as you as we
increase the intensity we get a higher
and higher mep or motor evoke response
and at some point it saturates but more
importantly this change from very little
activity being generated by the TMS
pulse to high activity generated by the
TMS pulse occurs in about a 10 volt per
meter range and so meaning that a
variation of 30 volts per meter is quite
significant and so the use of neuro
navigated procedures is important and so
there are also other uncertain
parameters that affect the electric
field for example there's coil
orientation on the stop so the coil
might be might might be placed correctly
but there might be errors in how its
oriented relative to the targeted neural
site finally there is a brain size which
can vary about twelve percent in between
individuals there's also conductivity
which is also highly variable not only
between tissues but also within tissues
here we only consider considered
uncertainty in the bulk conductivity of
each tissue and when we look at our
results for the same are aligned it
turns out that quote position
uncertainty is the most important one
followed by brain size which neural
navigated procedures can also account
for because they have the MRI coil
orientation and tissue conductivity
affect much less now it turns out that
here we're considering the magnitude of
the electric field if you were
considering the electric field along a
given direction coil eructation
would be important so that's something
to keep in mind and and so it turns out
that we just hit the tip of the iceberg
there's a certain level of uncertainty
and all the stimulation whistle and but
however this is the solvers viewpoint
you've given an input scenario
and it gives you a prediction while
neglecting that reality is really messy
you rarely see an experimental result
without some kind of error bars or some
kind of estimate or uncertainty
whereas with simulations oftentimes you
just get a single deterministic output
and so to increase the realism of our
simulations we must take into account
all of these inherent contingencies and
my brain research project addresses this
need and so here's what we're working
towards the goal is to make variation of
where soldiers take into account all of
these contingencies and produce not only
predictions but also confidence
intervals so what are the sources
someone has inherent uncertainties for
possible errors so there are
observational errors so for example
imaging data has movement artifacts or
partial volume effects meaning that
multiple tissues can recite on a single
box'll and so as a result the output
images are corrupted a corrupted
representation of the subject
furthermore the position where the coil
is placed on a stimuli and on a
simulation might not be reproducible
exactly in an experiment because of
limited precision in coil placement so
we have limited knowledge of where the
coil displays then there are modeling
error the imaging data is typically
segmented into tissue types so there
might be misclassification errors which
result in erroneous health models
furthermore how the coil is model
affects the solution we have done these
studies and it turns out that this is
negligible but nevertheless formally
there is a source of modeling error
there finally there are discretization
errors when we solve these things on a
computer
our solutions depend on the density of
the message used to discretize the head
and the order of our numerical methods
here I show a figure illustrating of
different meshes can result in widely
different solutions for the same
scenario in the end our goal is to
create a solver that not only generates
predictions for PMS induced electric
fields and we also want to predict
uncertainty resulting from all of these
things that I just mentioned
and then once we have all this we want
to use it to come up with coil
placements that not only maximize
electric fields that targeted particle
size but also minimize uncertainty or
inherent uncertainty in our procedures
I'll briefly talk about ongoing work I'm
doing to get to this vision that I have
to give you an idea of how we're pushing
towards this and so first goal was to
remove this critter stationary so what
we did is we put together all of the
methods used in the literature and some
new ones and compared them in terms of
error to figure out the optimal strategy
for reducing error while keeping
computational time tractable if you're
interested in using simulators in your
experiments I highly recommend our paper
and brain stimulation it provides
essential background for effective use
of simulators in an accessible matter
and all of these coats are available and
worked online and they work in Linux
Windows Mac you said using MATLAB
interfaces and so another thing we've
been looking at is how observational
errors affect the fidelity of our
simulation of books so as I said earlier
MRI images have movement artifacts and
partial volume effects and other sources
of error furthermore to generate a head
model using these MRIs
these MRIs they're typically passed
through these segmentation algorithms
and these segmentation algorithms can
miss classifying individual boxes
resulting in an erroneous head model so
to estimate these possible errors how
these possible errors result in
uncertainty in the predicted electric
field we treat tissue boundaries as
random variables here I show a CSF and
different realization of the CSF the
first slightly to account for tissue
boundary uncertainty then we can run a
Monte Carlo to determine the electric
field uncertainty due to possible errors
in the CSF discritization and here is an
output of the elect as expected electric
field and a standard deviation we are
currently extending this framework for
tissue interfaces like gray matter and
white matter
and so there's not only single subject
variability but there's also inter
subject their ability and analyzing this
in principle is quite easy to first get
a number of subject ed models and then
identify our license subject using any
functional MRI toolbox then for each we
can determine the coil position to be
field maps tell here it's plotted on a
hemispherical surface so this
hemispherical surface is a
transformation from the scalp to a
spherical and in the eg ornaments are
used to generate the snapping and so the
color of each of these individual the
color of these individual hemispheres
represents what electric field will be
generated at the coil is positioned at
that specific position on the scalp on
the targeted neural site and so then you
can combine these e field maps to and
integrate them to generate you feel
population level information on the e
field induced if a normalized coordinate
system is used for PMS and so this is a
particularly useful example for a
researcher studying some kind of disease
and wants to come up with a coil
placement that will minimize maximize
efficacy of the paradigm while
minimizing uncertainty across
individuals they can use this to
determine a position on in terms of EEG
coordinates to place the coil that can
be used across individuals and currently
so this currently all can be done it's
relatively straightforward however these
analysis are quite computationally
intensive and so what we're working in
is in developing best methods to make
doing these analysis on a laptop
possible so that this can be used in a
practical setting to inform oil
positioning and so this slide summarizes
my research accomplishments and I'll
read some of them to you so I developed
a first comprehensive UQ framework for
PMS obtained new insights into factors
that affect PMS variability
yes coil position just brain size no no
conductivity and no orientation and and
the idea here is to extend these
frameworks to develop TMS paradigms that
are robust coil placement errors and so
this don't set up thank you very much